[Music]
[Music]
we're here live with the aim experience
in Manhattan witnessing the return of
the Avengers for things they appear to
be attacking the city keep rolling keep
rolling
[Music]
is it any coincidence that this attack
comes on the very day that aim is
supposed to unveil their promising new
adaptoid program Oh
feel will thank you
you should know
wait is that for
holy crap door so the hell did you come
from I was serving a comment when it
started raining bolts of metal from the
skies unbelievably good to see you
dramatic don't you think
it doesn't matter he's here now returns
you did what you were supposed to do
forward you gave up your he's just a
forgotten
[Music]
[Music]
our v6 they're drilling into the deck
something called encodes up to crash the
chimera
hello
[Music]
just like old times in drop ships
inbound see them focus on those mechs
kamal are you okay yeah on my way hope
you got this
I will explain later don't worry she's
up to it
chimeras still losing altitude so can
you hold it up with wind apart
[Music]
you killed Captain America for who fall
before your hammer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're the terrorists in the same
experience story not on my watch
the camara can't go down not again
got it some drones heading for the
command deck got my hands full kid I'm
on them nice security subsystems just
came back online it's working
[Music]
you don't have to that's the whole point
force
the damage has already been done
Avengers
[Music]
come on let's Tony we're trying to
restart the engines but there's not
enough power we're out of telling people
brace for impact
hey got a Thunder stabilized
you
[Music]